E aí
[Música]
o Olá meu nome é Alisson Lisboa e eu vou
contar uma história para vocês o recorde
de uma foto antiga que meu pai tirou há
mais de 30 anos nela mostrava o meu
irmão estudando em uma mesa grande de
madeira e eu em detalhe dando um joinha
debaixo da cama enquanto ele estudava eu
só tava papagaio pulava muro ali na Rua
Frutal em Santa Efigênia Belo Horizonte
onde vive toda minha infância todos por
lá gostavam de ler eu não vivo só se for
juntar pó Mas que que eu podia fazer né
meu pai era professor e minha mãe
advogada ler era parte do Ofício lá
dentro de casa e o livro é coisa tão
velha acho que eu é tinha uma estante na
arca para rodada deles para passar o
tempo enquanto chovia lá fora quando eu
estava nas séries finais do Ensino
Fundamental Imagine só que perseguição a
professora pediu a turma para ler um
livro escrito por herberto Sales
sobradinho dos Pardais
é mais de onde saiu esse cara você tem
foi lançado em 1974 eu tinha acabado de
chegar ao berçário naquela mesma data e
vai saiu e foi comprar um livro
rapidamente né tinha que ler e
apresentar um trabalho chegava o dia da
apresentação e o livro tinha sumido mas
minha mãe não é mãe a mãe você sabe
desconfiada saiu e comprou outro livro
não deu outra eu continuei escondendo
esse livro eu não queria ler o
Sobradinho os Pardais esconde ele no
fundo falso da mochila minha mãe né como
uma boa mãe comprou mais um exemplar
desse livro ela não queria desistir eu
também não queria desistir de esconder e
pela terceira vez eu escondi a seria
foram três exemplares que eu escondi o
que eu tô contando essa história aqui né
eu vou dizer que esse esse resultado não
foi tão desastroso mas foi um caminho um
pouco tortuoso
eu coloquei outras prioridades na minha
vida e aos 21 anos de idade era pai
minha filha Luísa nasceu e não tinha
completado nem um segundo grau eu
colocava adesivos de roqueiros nos
livros de história de ciências muitos
não tinha nem marcas de uso o gosto pela
leitura tinha nem ideia o que que é isso
não gostava realmente dele mas os 28
anos a coisa tomou outro rumo e eu
resolvi começar a escrever a história da
minha vida fiz objetivo no colégio São
Luiz Gonzaga uniforme azul-marinho com
brasão grande no peito quase uma
condenação para mim os Muros da Escola
era alto demais para fugir não dava para
eu sair correndo e os colegas de sala
toda entre 15 e 16 anos e eu com uma
vergonha tremenda de estar ali minha
filhota crescendo EA vida me pedindo
mais não queria ver a minha história se
repetir naquele ser em formação duvidar
da escola fugir da Leitura meus dias de
descaso pelo contato com os livros
chegaram ao
é a vontade de ser outro bateu forte mas
a mágica do encontro do enamoramento aí
com a leitura foi aos poucos páginas
começaram a virar terminei o supletivo
Finalmente eu venci a fórmula de
Bhaskara entrei para a faculdade quatro
anos depois eu era bacharel em
jornalismo trabalhava na época como
diagramador de jornais o gosto pela
leitura tomou o corpo volume levantou
voo como um belo Pardal vieram as
oportunidades decidi me especializar em
produção em mídias digitais entrei para
PUC Foi aí que pintou a ideia de
embarcar numa nova e Incrível Jornada
fui para a Espanha fazer mestrado virem
mestre em comunicação digital interativa
Quanta ironia o tema desse Ted x são as
tecnologias que transformarão o mundo e
não é apenas falar de um homem que
há duas Barreiras que rompeu para uma
vida onde tudo é possível quero mais
quero propagar e devolver o que aprendi
ao longo de duas décadas retornei da
Europa e foi convidada a falar sobre a
minha experiência no exterior ao
terminar a minha fala o professor me
convidou a fazer parte do quadro de
professores do IEC da PUC Minas começava
ali a minha jornada como professor uma
das maiores alegrias da minha vida
voltei para a redação do Jornal Estado
de Minas onde trabalhava mal conseguindo
conter a alegria pelo convite a vida
prega Peças na gente nos ensina e coloca
tudo em seu devido lugar Este ano
completa dez anos como professor
universitário descobri que estar neste
mundo é está fazendo o quê que eu mais
quero porque o sonho essa minha
descoberta a descoberta de quem esconde
a livros
Esse é o amor em ensinar ensinar ensinar
cada vez mais e aprender com os alunos
estudarem propagar conhecimento ensinar
as pessoas a gostar que gostar de livros
falo deles mostra as vídeo-aulas faço
resenhas abraço indistintamente a visão
caleidoscópio de todos os autores que me
chegam às mãos são eles os meus guias
meus mentores
a frase que eu gosto muito diga-me e eu
esquecerei ensina-me e eu poder lembrar
envolva-me e eu aprenderei essa frase de
Benjamin Franklin ele sabia das coisas
antes eu não estava envolvido não sentia
a mudança dentro de mim e senti que não
é apenas passar conhecimento para o
aluno é preciso também envolvê-lo os
Pardais voo vão para bem longe Eles
talvez não voltem mais os livros e o que
eles nos passam ficam não nos abandonam
nunca traz todos os anos em que foi
professor busquei aproximar o mercado de
trabalho da sala de aula as práticas de
oficinas mão na massa eram sempre
constantes eu terminar as aulas como
quem acabava de praticar algum esporte
eu tava muito cansado mas também muito
feliz não precisava convencer era
preciso envolver a todos que tiverem e
todos que te ouvem no final de 2017
eu recebi o telefonema do Coordenador
Leonardo do colégio cotemig me convidava
para lecionar empreendedorismo
disciplina que é envolvimento puro tempo
todo aceitei o convite fiz uma aula
teste passei a integrar o quadro de
professores estavam de férias e pediram
que eu descansar seu para o ano que ele
ia começar o desafio com certeza estava
por vir no primeiro dia de aula lá
estavam eles sentado em fileiras
curiosos e ansiosos para conhecer o novo
professor
e por um instante eu parei eu me vi em
cada um daqueles rostos 7 turnos com 50
alunos em média em cada sala eram 350
oportunidades diante dos meus olhos
querer fazer diferente do que fiz quando
tinha a idade deles fiquei um tempo
parado olhando não podia pedir a eles
que lessem sobradinho dos Pardais
precisávamos alçar voos mais altos e
assim eu fiz Saímos da sala de aula
fizemos oficinas no pátio dos temos
convidados falamos do Poder
transformador dos livros e nos
envolvemos com suas histórias querer que
todos eles pudessem viver experiências
Para Além da sala de aula e a mudança
começou a descartáveis e o
empreendedorismo não estão nos livros
estão nas ruas os espaços de inovação os
Coworking e para lá que vamos
eu combinei com a escola a vida e pronta
para os desafios alugamos um ônibus
fizemos a rota empreendedora e partimos
para o dia inteiro diversão
e foram palestras visitas técnicas aos
espaços e o envolvimento que me fez
sentir asas batendo forte e ganhando os
céus era visível o brilho nos olhos dos
meus alunos eles puderam viver as
histórias perguntar encontrar sentido em
tudo aquilo que era dito nos livros
conseguimos envolver a escola os pais os
alunos os outros professores a direção
os empresários envolvemos todos
trouxemos os livros abertos com
histórias reais a rota empreendedora
passou a fazer parte da disciplina
tivemos a lesão de boa parte dos alunos
Eu lavava a minha alma e transbordava de
alegria na volta alunos cansados no
ônibus que deixaria eles na porta da
escola era possível ver a expressão de
quem pensa e absorve o momento podemos
pular muros soltar papagaios brincar e
conhecer o mundo Basta que os
professores abram seus livro
e me contem a história de outro jeito
sempre há outro modo de ver as coisas o
livro uma tecnologia incrível que
permite inclusive novos modos de narrar
envolver o conhecimento encontra no
papel se o suporte ideal e no Professor
o seu maior Guardião não precisamos
esconder os livros precisamos
praticá-los outro dia em minha casa
acordei assustado com o barulho a
estante dos livros não suportou o peso e
caiu Gostei da oportunidade eu espalhei
pela casa todos os livros caídos e tenho
sempre alguma mochila não posso
deixá-los ao relento preciso trazê-los
para bem perto de mim essa um pouco da
minha história que o que de trazer no
Ted x aqui do cotemig Gostaria que você
pensasse um pouco sobre a transformação
do livro sobre a transformação da sala
de aula e a responsabilidade do
professor quer mudar cada um com seu
poder de cortar uma boa
e olha muito obrigado